before jumping into something let me
tell you what you are going to learn
from this uh
video tutorial what's the purpose of it
so first
let us understand what is react native
and why you have to learn it
react native is a popular a very popular
cross
platform library that is based on react
but it's not necessarily
same uh and it is a very cool thing and
it allows you to build
applications both on the android devices
and ios devices like iphone
ipod and etc so this is a very cool
uh and the reason that it is cool is
that before or not
not far before people were used to
learn a native technologies like for
example
if you want to build an application for
android device
you should have learned android studio
so java and all of that all the new
libraries
all that new headaches so that's the
cool thing about react native
first it is very powerful it
it as the name suggests react native it
brings you the experience of
native development like you do on a
swift and android studio
and it makes a cool applications for
both of the devices
so you save time you save resources
you save money and everyone is happy
so why why should you learn it why
should you learn react native
so we understood that it is very fast
very powerful
and it is very demanded on the market
because
the most important thing is to get a
valid
a good product that will satisfy the
customers satisfy the stakeholders
and it will be fast and
very efficient you know in a manner of
economy
so the learning outcome from this course
is going to be how
to uh set up the react native inside
your computer
how to build things with it and
overall you will walk you through the
javascript
walk you through the most important
react native components
which will give you a good base a good
foundation we are not going to
go deep inside to explain each variable
because we are going to assume that
the one who looks at this video is have
already some experience with javascript
and react native
but we are going to give you the
explanation of the how the project is
already built
uh how the components work and interact
with each other
and we'll talk some of the difficult
steps so first of all
we are going to install and set up the
environment
so in order to set up environment you
need java no
java for the back end
so there are some things that are based
on the java so you just have to install
you don't need to worry about it
we are not going to do anything with it
and then you are going to
install the node.js which is the most
important thing that the react native is
based on it
then we are going to get an editor where
we are going to write our code
uh in thing in editors i
am not limiting anyone so if you if you
are free to use
subtitle or uh
sublime or atom or
visual code it doesn't matter really we
don't care about it too much
but i will highly suggest that you use
microsoft visual code or atom because
they are
designed for react native and it will be
more easier for you to use it and work
with it
then we are going to install android
studio
why because uh we have to demonstrate
somehow the project and as soon as we
type inside
the editor we want to see how the
changes are directly made
that's why we are going to bring the
emulator on the right side and the code
on the left side
and we are going to write the code and
see the changes
change the code and see what what lead
it to us
eventually you do not need to have an
android simulator on your
computer if you have a usb cable and you
have the android
device physically available for you you
can just plug it
inside the computer and drawn from the
terminal command which
which i will tell you uh later and after
that
you are going to able to test it and see
the application
directly on your device yeah and there
will be some installations like android
studio installation result constitution
node.js installation and i would like
you to follow
me through this installations why
because
uh i will not i first of all i would not
recommend you to do
the node.js and some other installations
by your own by following some guide on
the internet
because uh this thing is crazy actually
some versions are not working with each
other so for example
we are going to install node.js 12.10.0
version and if you install one
uh let's say the latest version if my
memory is not failing me
it's the 14 version 14.
if you install it there will give you a
bunch of errors maybe there is a
solution for that errors i'm not sure
you can check on the google
if you are so sure that you want to use
the latest version
but uh if you uh if you follow me up
you can ask me questions after the video
uh you can
and i'm going to fix the most backs that
can
occur during this installation okay so
as i said the first thing with that we
need
is uh to set up the environment uh
so the first our first steps will be to
set up the environment
and after setting the up environment
we'll go already the
coding part where we will just install
the editor that we are interested in
in my case i will use the result code
you can
i will not show you the installation of
visual code or android studio because
this is not necessarily what we need to
cover and there is no
difference between the version the only
thing i i will show you
is how to connect the react native and
the virtual emulator together
so let's go for the let's go
before you also one thing i would like
to mention is
how uh in order to motivate you kind of
i would like to show you how will our
project look like this is not going to
be exactly the same
as our project but it is going to be
similar to it
and the most important thing if you
follow up the
project code if you look at the code and
you understand it
the thing you see right in front of you
in the picture
is going to be just a very easy thing
for you to do
it is not going to be exactly the same
but we are going to have
a pictures next to each other we are
going to have labels on it we are going
to have menu we are going to have
uh discuss how you can navigate from one
screen to another screen
you will be able to scroll horizontally
and vertically
so overall you will gain going to get
the foundation in react native
from after all if you are interested you
can build on it
get a knowledge and basically build your
building and achieve
hopefully any other good project so yeah
so as i said the first step is the uh
installation and setting up google
then in the google we are going to type
node.js we'll go to the
first website as you can see
there is a download for the windows
windows uh the 64-bit uh
64-bit architecture it already directly
detected for me
so in case uh if it doesn't
detect you can type here like mac or
linux and it will
bring you the correct installation as
you can see recommended
for most users the current one is 14 and
the recommended is 12
because the 14 is kind of a very
better version alpha version people are
testing it people getting
problems with it but even the the one
that is recommended is not actually
working pretty well
so i will go for the other downloads and
i'll try to find here uh
the previous releases so previous
releases
so we are interested in the 12
let me remind myself we are interested
in 12.10
right so we'll go for the version branch
and le let us go here again
oops it's not here okay yeah i'm sorry
so you have to scroll down basically you
have to scroll down and you can see that
all versions are available here
that you're interested in 12.10 and it
have to be
zero right yeah so we'll go for the 12.0
this one
so we'll click download and then it will
bring
us to kind of an index of all downloads
available
as we are going to install on the
windows windows 10 operation system
64-bit architecture
we are going to download the x64 dot
msi
uh we'll we'll wait for a little bit so
okay the download got completed
okay so we'll click next i accept the
terms
next you will choose the location you
want next
next install the necessary tools
oh we actually don't need it next
finish okay so for now we have already
installed
the node.js the main component that
we need in order to create react native
projects
uh the second most important thing is to
create the virtual
emulator the virtual device that we are
going to run the project on
so in order to do that we have to
install android studio
it's very easy to do you just have to go
google
type the android
studio and download the latest version
from their website
i'm not going to go through the
installation of android studio because
it's very basic you have to
just follow the uh default
next next process so it's of
installation
so i'm going to close it now the thing
that i think it's important that you
have to consider
is how to get the device
uh itself created so in order to in on
virtual uh
on android studio in order to create a
virtual device
you are going to go to android studio uh
you will see on the right
top corner there is a phone with the
android icon
you are going to click on it then as you
uh
you will get in a window popped up that
in your case there will be no pixel 2
api 29
uh because it's a virtual device that i
already created before
but in order to create a new virtual
device you're going to click here create
virtual device
then select uh the virtual device you're
interested in you can see the resolution
the density whether it supports play
store no
so in my case i selected the pixel 2
because it's one of the latest versions
then you click next uh i would highly
suggest
to select the highest android version
that is possible
in my case it's android 10
because it is supported with the most
recent
react native components so because if
you install the different version
maybe there will be some issues that are
not fixed before
so yeah after after installing the pixel
api 29 you can you can click to start
to see whether it works
yep for me it works uh and that's it for
the installation of the android studio
and the creating a virtual device now on
we will
move forward create a project uh i'll
i'll show you how you can create a
project from terminal for
node.js then we'll go to the project
first i will show you the demo how the
project looks like
then we'll dive how the components were
used okay so i want to congratulate you
almost reach to the step that we are
going already to show you
how the project looks like itself and
before
running the project from the terminal
with the android studio
there is some more preconfigurations
that we have to do
it may seem a little bit tricky for
someone who is not used to do things
they use is not used to configure
android studio before
or working with the operation system
much so if someone
has no programming experience but
it's a very easy process if you are
using a physical device you can just
download the xbox application on it as i
said before
uh then by downloading the expo
application you rather
either plug your android device with the
usb
or you just you take article the camera
is from inside the application bring it
near to the
barcode in the website that we are going
to show now
and you will get access but as as i'm
going to show you on the android studio
let me show the configuration then i
will show you how you can do it in an
easier way
so first of all let me open the
requirements that we have here first
we are going to uh uh install android
sdk
in order to do the android sdk
installation and platform
and installation of the platform tools
we need to go to the android studio
so let me run it
[Laughter]
running there but you don't need to care
about that it doesn't matter if you have
the project
order it can be just blank so you go
file
settings then from inside settings
you are going to go appearance system
settings
android sdk from there you are going to
click
sdk tools then for
for for someone who just downloaded
android studio
he or she will not have the following uh
check boxes checked so you are going to
check the android sdk build
tools checkbox android sdk command line
tools
the latest version android emulator
android sdk platform tools and of course
the intel
intel emulator accelerator we need this
in order to run the second
device inside our our operation system
because it's a kind of other
operation system is going to run inside
our main operation system so that's why
we need
the emulator accelerator so we are going
to click ok
it's going to take some time to install
it's around one
gigabyte if my memory is not failing me
so yeah
after installation you will get a folder
inside your if you go to your app
data if you go to this folder you can
hear
this folder uh this folder is the
the default called the normal operation
systems to access it you are going
just to search bar putting the
percentage sign
app data and data
and the percentage sign closing you will
enter here then you will go back from
the roaming folder
local then us local then you will go uh
you will see there is a folder called
android you will see inside this folder
there is an
another folder called sd key if you see
this folder
and you enter inside and again you see
build tools platforms platform
tools then you it means that you have
correctly installed
you have correctly installed android
studio and the platform
that we have just required from you also
it states
that you have installed a virtual device
in your android studio
so after after seeing that the folder
exists you're going to
copy the path and you're going to add
this path to your
system so you can access this path from
anywhere in the command line
so in order to do that you can either
run these three commands
you can run either this com three
commands by changing here
uh the path you have so you basic
usually
uh like 99 it's the same place it's apb
data local android sdk platform tools
the only thing you have to change
is this part so see what kind of you
what kind of uh
hard drive on which letter of hard drive
you're running it
which user you are just change it and
add this to the pop
you can you can either run this command
one by one like by just going to cmd
uh copying this one and passing there or
if you are not well enough with the
command line
you can go to the computer
uh my computer right click on it then
properties and here you are going to go
to advanced
setting which is on the left side then
it's advanced settings you're going to
do
again advanced properties and here you
can see that there is a puff
you are going to double click on the
puff and then click
create here you will have a crate then
after going to create you are going to
enter the the enter these lines that are
already
uh entered for me so i have entered it
before
so you're just going to create uh click
create then you're going to pass it
just here and that's it click enter and
then
the last step that you have to do is
create a variable
android home just same as here so you
can look at the video and same as here
and enter this path so not platform to
not not platform tools no no not tools
not platform tools no platforms
just android sdk with the variable name
of
android home to do that you're just
going to click
here create the name of the variable
which is android home
and the destination of it which you see
users for for markets turbo a app data
updater local android sdk after doing
that
we're going to click ok ok and that's
it we are going to close everything up
the next
thing we already have to do is
create our project so let's say i am
someone
who already have set up everything and i
want to create
uh i want to create already the project
from scratch so what do i do
in order to create the project we are
going to go to our command line
so i'm going to type cmd here enter the
command line then
uh on the desktop i'm going to create a
new folder called react native
as you can see it's already created for
me uh
then i'm going to access to that folder
via the command line to do that we are
going to do a cd desktop
then inside from the desktop we are
going to do cd react native you can put
any folder name of course you want
then in order to create a project from
scratch
in expo you need to write around the
following command
the full the command name is called npx
expo cla init and
the name of the project uh name of the
application
or etc yeah so
this one uh the mpx is going to be
available for you as as you remember
from the
uh from uh from the little earlier that
we have discussed
you can run uh a node.js from your
command line and if
at the commands response back it means
the npx is installed for you
so in order to do that uh in order to
create the application
we are going to write npx expo
i
and the name of the project let's call
the project name
test1
so then it will ask us for a template so
what's the difference between difference
between creating a project with the expo
and creating a project from scratch uh
the
default one that react native provides
you the expo
gives you a good template that you can
build your project
up on it so the the files the external
files
the update uh app.js
is already created for you you don't
need to manually configure
the size and hey and everything so it's
basically just a template that you can
build your project up
uh for beginner it may sound like okay
what's the difference we would like to
dig more
but you will understand it only as soon
as you enter inside
the thing so we are going to create the
blank so it's going to be a minimal
office cleaners empty canvas
so it's going to be a clean template
that will allow us
sorry to allow us to build our project
only so i'm going to click
enter it's going to take
a little bit of time
yeah so what we are going to do now now
after the installation of the javascript
dependencies and the
template is created over we are going to
run
we are going to run it there is actually
two
uh three ways of running it in the expo
tli
either you can run it in a browser
because you know that react native is
based on react they have
similarities so it gives you the chance
of running
it on a web browser or you can run it
later or you can run on it a physical
device
so now uh as you can see your our
project is ready as it states here
if you get this com i get this uh uh
pro get this alert back then it's your
project it's ready
so in order to do that we are going to
go to the folder
that was just created by expo
uh the folder name is going to be the
name that you just gave to the project
well the project name was test one so
i'm going to do
cd test one okay so i'm inside
so in order to run this project we have
to do expo
start as you can see
it just created it just opened a port
1902 on our local host
and we have a beautiful ground web
api uh web application sorry and
web in this uh in our screen
you can see that on the left side
we have few rows that says run an
android device simulator run an ios
simulator
run in web browser publish republish
project and a barcode there so
what is use this barcode for what the
barcode is there for
if you have installed the expo
application inside the expo application
you can see a screen you can see there
scon qr qr code and as soon as you bring
the camera with that
feature near to your screen it will
kind of very in a very nice way scan it
and display your application uh
on your uh physical device without any
connections without anything just you
have to be on the same internet
sounds cool right but we are not going
to do that
but as i'm going to demonstrate it and
you have to see it here
i will do it in an android simulator so
i am going to click on the run android
device simulator
but actually i will show it on the you
on the project that is already created
and created
now i'm going just to show you how it
works so i'm going to click
run in the web browser
because it's attempting to open the
project in a web browser
starting webpack on board and that's it
as you can see uh on the on the title
you can see that it's a test one
and it says open up app.js to start
working on
your app this is just a text
uh it's just a label that is the by
default
created in our app.js
js file so this is not a warning this is
nothing this is just a text box
so if you get the screen it means just
that's it it clearly works and
we have to start already to build our
project
okay so let's go to the our visual code
editor
and see how our new created project
looks like by scratch
in the scratch way like the default way
how it looks like
so i'm going to click on the visual code
editor here
then i'm going to click file open folder
as you can see i'm on the desktop and
the react native folder
and there is a folder called test1 so
click on it
yeah and that's it it's there so let me
maximize it for you
as you can see we have a few files there
and the most important files that i
would like to talk about
is not not modules not modules
stand for the modules or the libraries
that you have installed on it
so this is the libraries that you have
to take care of so
there's some components then when you
when you want to use
inside your application you have to
install it which will talk a little bit
later
so this is the libraries you have
installed on uh you have
this is a web build that was just
created for a web web one
uh the one that we have around in the
browser and the most important one that
we
have to know about is the app.js
now this is the this is the thing that
we just have seen
here so if i bring the two two uh
two two of them right next to each other
you can see that
it's a just on a text or a text
text a text tag with an
open up app.js to start working on your
program so you can see it's it's uh
we have the same thing here so if i
start to
uh change it to something else it will
get changed here also
as okay as you can see it directly
reactively in a way it's changed the
thing so it's just a text box
nothing else so let me talk a little bit
about what's going on on this
simple project so first we're importing
the libraries that we
need in order to proceed so this one is
the kind of a common one that we have to
uh import so we will start to work in a
react
platform then we are importing style
stylesheet is used to to style the
the objects that you have on your screen
so as you can see
uh we have uh yeah
uh and there is a text which is used for
a text tag and view
is kind of if you are from a web
development background it's that
is say similar to a div so
a view is kind of a container that you
can put your objects together
so in react native in order if you want
uh if you want to put
uh some uh some uh multiple objects
together
in order to do that you have to have a
container so view stands for a good
container so you can put
multiple text boxes together and we put
a style of this view object to a style
container sorry and the background
this is the background color a line item
justify content and both
this for the whole justify content
stands for the
horizontal aligning and align items
for the very vertical aligning so both
of them are on the center
so that's why the open up dot js
is this kind of in other words this
one line of code is right in the middle
of the screen
so uh let's be open the project
that you are interested in uh the one
that we have created
and we want to show show it with you
share it with you
and so you will have a better idea a
more clear idea
how the projects look like in iraq
native and how powerful is it
so in order to do that first thing we
have to do
is go to the android studio
as we open the android studio we are
going we are going to
run the uh android virtual emulator uh
manager
which is on the right corner of the
android studio so i'm going to click on
it
then i'm going to run the virtual device
that we have installed
before so i'm going to click start
so you will have your android device on
your right side let me make it a little
bit
smaller so it will not cover all the
screen yeah
so do we are going to go to the
command line as we did for the test one
then we are going to change the folder
change the folder to
the project folder that we are
interested in in my case
project for uh project folder is called
food
i called it fold for just for four
letters so it will be more easier rather
than restaurant application
uh don't worry you will be provided for
the for the code and the food folder
you just concentrate the things i'm
doing here and try to learn from it
so i'm going to the food folder then i'm
going to run as soon as you are
in the folder of the project you are
going to write expo start
browser uh in this in this time we are
not going to run it in a browser we are
going to run it in the
later it's okay so as soon as you are in
the browser you click run
on android devices later
it's it's going to open uh on android
device so let's see what's happening
here
building the javascript bundle it may
take some time depending on the
performance and hardware of your
computer
so hello there let me make it a little
bit
bigger yeah so hello there
science is your first time okay got it
thank you let's close this
by x it's just a welcoming screen
okay so here is our up already running
there
i think it would be more greater if it'd
be more bigger yeah
you can see our app has a search bar
icon there with the title also there and
it has a it has a cost effective section
it has has a bit pricier section
it has also uh another section with the
highest value
which is not here because this kind of
restaurants don't have the hot
that that section so it's not it's not
going to just show us
so you can see you can uh you can
by in a real physical device you will be
able to scroll it by a finger
but here i'm going to show you with the
mouse so you can see you can scroll
you can score uh here also right and
left
and let's say you are interested in one
of the restaurants
for example
and you can see as soon as you click on
it it's going to give you the
description
of the uh specific restaurant and you
will be able to scroll there
to see more images from that restaurant
so here is the project also you can
search for let's say you're interested
in
pizza so
let's look for pizza so it's going to
search through the api
find the pizzas there and again let's
click on one of the pizzas
and again we get another other pictures
with the description
so this is the product overall that we
are
and let's jump into the code
okay so let's talk about the code
in order to run in order to see the code
we have to go to the our visual code
editor
then go file open folder
then click on the folder that it will be
provided in a github
or in the description so you're gonna
double click on it
and click yes select the folder so
you are inside the video studio so what
i'm going to do in order
in in in order to tell you which
component
gives what which idea i'll bring the two
windows next to each other
so we will see clearly so
i i will open the picture also
just one second
yeah so okay
so this is the this is the project and
this is the
this is the project and this is the code
of the project that we're interested in
so let's start from the beginning we
have a lot of files here
and for first it can be confusing for
experienced developer
it may sound easy so for what we are
going to do first we are going to talk
about what we have in app
json app.js file then
we are going to have a look what
components screens hooks
and apis we have here so
uh what what we have in app.js
as i said app.js is the main file that
we are interested in
this is the main file where everything
goes in here we are going to create
a navigator constant navigator constant
it is like when you declare something
like this in react native
it is a function then this is the way
that you declare a function inside
a react native and this is the name of
the function what create stack navigator
function is going to do
it is going to create a navigator that
will allow the user to navigate from one
screen to another screen
we are going to have two screens here
the first screen
is going to be the main screen which is
the cost where we have cost effective
big sender bit prior price here and the
menu out there
the second screen which is going to be
result show screen
is as soon as you click on one of the
restaurants that you are interested in
and you move to the uh to the
appropriate menu
where you will see the description and
more images about the file
so so we create here two variables
uh screen one and screen two uh with the
name of research and resolve show
then we are going to put the initial
road name as attribute we're just going
to see
say which screen is going to pop up
first so this one
as we are going to pop up the first
search screen the this screen
then we will put the initial route name
to search if we change this and put
results show
then it is going to show uh the first
screen
uh it will give error actually because
it doesn't know which screen to show
actually
then we have a title uh as you can see
here is written search screen
and we have a search screen here and
explore default create up content this
is just by default that we have to do
but before doing this we have to import
some stuff
that will allow us to navigate from
screen to screen
in order to uh import this we have to
write the following command lines and
from the command line
we have to go to the command line
navigate to the project
folder
[Applause]
after navigating there we have to go and
install the dependencies in order to
install react navigation
we have to write mpx install react
navigation
and npx install react navigation stack
don't worry this commands will be given
to you
in order to install both of them so
after installation you will be
uh you will be able to uh sorry i
misclicked
yeah so you will be able to uh
use the following imports so okay we
have we have covered the apb.json
so let's look what else we have here
so as i said we have created two screens
out here
so let's talk about each screen so let's
talk about the main screen we have there
i created a folder when you see things
there
screens hooks and components api they're
actually folders
so i make i divide it into four folders
so it'll be more easier for
the developer other developers to
understand
so i put a screen where which is going
to be
the main screens out there so let's go
from the uh main screen
search screen what we have here so first
uh
let's start from the design then we'll
go inside the
inside details so we have a search bar
we have a search bar component out there
which is as you can see the search
search bar where we can type and it is
an icon
so so as you can see it's a search bar
component
and we have a flexo one which is going
to take the whole entire container here
all upper part we have used the flex
style so it will make the
all upper part then inside the search
bar
we have other three components result
list result list result list
so each result list is
uh one container one whole container
so result this first result list is the
cost effective
the second result list is bit price here
the third result list
is big sender so we have divided this
three
this whole menu into three sections cost
effective bid price here big center so
that's why we have three result lists
and we have one search bar that is top
of all of them
then we have a title as you can see uh
we put a title attribute
cost effective bid price here big
spender then we have a navigation here
this is used for passing the variable
from there we're going to pass
this variable so our application will
understand
that this is what has a one dollar sign
hence
it's a cost effective if it's a double
dollar sign it's a bit pricier if it's a
triple dollar sign
then it's a big spender okay so
how do we get this uh oh yeah also and
one thing i would like to mention
is that we have a scroll view here what
does scroll view mean
scroll view as you saw we were able to
scroll
down and up uh so if k
in case uh the we want to see what's in
the big sender as you can
see the screen is not able to cover the
big sender but we will be able to scroll
it down
and see hence to do that we have to take
this
all resolve this and put under scroll
screen section
you can actually make a
tab so that it will be under the strong
screen so it will be more clearer for
you
yes and we have a search bar also there
as i said
so that's it for for the screen
other things i would like to cover is
this one this is a kind of a set
function
that it says it will change as soon as
you type something here
uh it will change the term and se
to with the function of search term
sector
as you can see the set term is used
inside the search bar
as soon as you type something in the bar
this variable this variable will be get
changed
and use state is used for a default
value so the defined value of the search
bar is empty so if i type something here
it will get changed here so hence it's
empty and it's used set term function
to change the term here so let's go so
let's discuss about this result list and
search bar components how do we get them
we are going to create a components
result list and search bar
so it will be more clearer more
effective
more let's say beautifully designed
so it will so everything would not be in
one page we could of course
define and declare everything in one
search screen
but we have i have uh divided it into
components uh folder hooks folder so it
would be
more easier for to understand so let's
go for the search bar
as you can see in the search bar let me
open it
we have a bunch of styles uh like
background color
so it would be a little bit gray the hay
the border radius
the border radius actually makes the
round box on the box around
the search bar around then we have
margin horizontal
so it will bring it right in the middle
a flex direction in a row so it would be
in the row position
uh the input style what what kind of
input it is going to take
and the icon style because we are going
to have icon there
so it i think this is very easy uh so
we're not going
much much on it the feeder is the icon
so and it's inside the view container as
you can see the icon is here
so we want to put the text box text
input place
near the with the icon so we are going
to put both of them in a views
view container and there is going to be
the text input
the text input is the input where we are
going to put everything over here
as you can see from the uh search screen
we are
calling it out here and we are changing
the text here
but in order to use it we have to define
some stuff
uh so for us and there is a few
attributes like how to capitalize that
we don't want to to be turned on how to
correct we are also putting in a force
sorry uh yeah and the placeholder is
going to be search
uh place order is going to be searched
uh because
uh we want to show that user what it's
going to be you can put it
anything we want and we are going to put
in the style that is going to use the
input style
and that's it for the search bar so
let's go to the
uh so we have covered the search bar
now let's talk about the results list
what is it and
why why do why are we even calling it so
let's go to result list
okay so in our result list again we have
a few
okay so we have we are understanding or
as soon as we
see view we we understand that there is
a container and inside the container we
have a text
and what what is the name of the text
it says a title but where is the title
title
is inherited from the search screen
class
and inside the search screen class you
can see the title equals to cost
effective
the way you inherit from one class to
other
so for example the components inherits
from the
search screen right so let's go result
list and you can see that we have import
uh we have inherited
from here we have inheritance here so
soon as you
declare the result list uh this function
and you see there that there is a title
results navigation here as as you can
see here it means
we are inheriting it from the class that
calls
this function so in the in the search
screen
we are getting called right this results
list is called and it is given
the title variable okay so here what i
say
i say okay i'm going to take the title
variable result variable and navigation
variable
and i'm going to use it inside my class
so i
i have inherited it uh so as soon as i
have inherited it i'm going to put
it as the title of my text so this one
is going to be called three times
because we have called the
result list three times so we have cost
effective big price here and big sender
so we are going to put and we have a
flat list so
what is flat list flat list is kind of
an
array in react native this is a
when you see a flat list it means there
is an array
so how we are going to set a data inside
the array so the data of
this array is going to be the results
the results we will talk a little bit
later which we are going to get from the
yelp api
yelp.js the key instructor is how we are
going to index it we are going to index
it with the result.id
a results have id so we'll talk about it
and we are going to render it
rend rendering uh i hope so uh people
know what the word rendering means it's
just like kind of ordering
uh how we are going what we are going to
set up there we are going to set the
items
the item is uh each result the
the small array inside the uh each index
inside the result array
and we are going to have a touchable
opacity touchable opacity
is just a box that is invisible and it
can be clickable
so it's touchable but it's invisible
so as you can see this one the picture
here
the pasta fresca if i'm spelling it
right
you can see it's an image but
in a project as soon as you run it you
can click on it
and you will get to the description i
hope you remember so
you can click on it and go to the
description but it is empty there is no
borders it doesn't look like button but
it's touchable
and inside that we have a result detail
result detail
holds the description of the
uh hold the description of the
of the current object current restaurant
in our case
all the uh whole details about it
and we have a if we have it under the
components folder
and on-press is a function inside react
native
that uh it works like in a way if you
if you have experience with c-sharp uh
or android studio or
any other graphical user interface if
not uh
it's very similar what i wanted to say
but if you are not familiar with it
it's just a way that tells the user what
is going to do the attachable opacity
the button or text mode
when it is clicked on it when it's
pressed so what we said
as soon as it press go to the result
detail
so what what we have installed the
result detail result detail
we have an image a set of images we have
a text
and text is the result name the name of
the restaurant and we have the rating
stars
and the reviews as you can see there and
some styles there
so that's it for uh for for the
components
and screens let's talk about yelp.js so
what we are going to do
we are going to get this restaurant
restaurant
from a yelp.js api this yet.js api is
very easy
you have to just import axios from axios
then put the
base url as you can see here and you
have to get
you you will get you have to type here
the api key
that you got from the yelp.yap.com it's
very easy you just
have to register that get your api put
the name
viewer here here and just pass through
your api here and that's it you're ready
to set it up
so you just need to pass it there is
nothing to think about it you have to
just copy and paste it
and import it there so thank you very
much
uh this was that's it for the uh project
uh i hope many things were clear for you
if you have any doubts
any question you can ask me uh
we have covered most of it but of course
for a beginner it can be
a little bit confusing but don't worry
every everyone starts from something
so if you have any questions again you
can ask and you can manipulate this
project
you're free to manipulate this project
there is no copyright for
it you can manipulate the project add
union staffs or use it
somewhere else thank you very much